Okay,solet'sstartwithaverybizarrepressconferencethatDonaldTrumpgavewherehedidall
sortsofthingsthatmakeverylittlesense.AndwhatIwannapointoutaboutthispressconference
inparticular,isthatDonaldTrumpseemsbarelyconsciousinthispressconferenceofthebone
whiteeyesinthemiddleofanorangefacehiseyeshalfclosedhesoundslikehe'sonambientor
downersbarelyawakeandreminder,thisisaclipofapressconferenceaboutcover19andthe
deathofapatient,andTrumpisramblingincoherentlyaboutISIS.Slurringsniffingshortofbreath,
03/03/20 Page4of16
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­02­commercialfree
takealookandlistenatthisfirstclipfromthisbizarrepressconference.
Again,it'sbeenalongjourney.AndAfghanistaninparticular,it'sbeenaverylongjourney,it's
beenahardjourneyforeverybody.We'reverylargelyalawenforcementgroupandthat'snotwhat
oursalesareallabout.Theirfightersarethegreatestfightersintheworldasyouknowwe've
destroyedinSyriaandtrack100%oftheICScaliphate100%,wehavethousandsofprisoners
we'vekilledhighorfightersbythethousands,thelaboredbreathing,combinedwithhisbarely
awakevoiceandramblingaboutISIS,it'sallveryweird.Thenhere'sTrumpstrangelytalkingabout
thesacrificesthathavebeenmade,inAfghanistanandhecomesaparttalkingabouttheexpenditure
oftreasuretheexpenditureoftreasureinthefight.Again,whatonearthisthisguytalkingabout
seeminglyanambulance?
Iguess,mostofall,IwannathankallofthepeopleintheUnitedStatesforhavingspentsomuchin
termsofblood,intermsoftreasureandtreasury.Themoneythathasbeenspentthelivesthathave
beenlost,andwejustsignedanagreementthatputsusinapositiontogetitdone,bringusdownto
inthevicinity,000trips,theUnitedNationswasinformedofeverythingandNATOhasbeengreat
circuitry,"Altenburghasbeenfantastic.Again,theextremelyslowspeechthelaboredbreathing,
thesnipingandnotmakingoneiotaofsensethenincomes.MikePencewhoisrememberhe's
runningthiswholething,willfollowuponthat,componentaswellandsaystravelisbeingbanned
toIranandwatchTrumpinthebackground,seeminglike"he'sstrugglingtostayawake.
ThetaskforcemetthismorningandbroughtthePresidentarangeofoptionsandathisdirection,
wewillbedoingthefollowing:First,thePresidentauthorizedactiontodaytoaddadditionaltravel
restrictionsonaram,wewillbeusingSection212F.I'mbanningtravelfromaranch.
Iranisalreadyunderatravelban,butweareexpandingexistingtravelrestrictionstoincludeany
foreignnationalwhoisvisitedaroundwithinthelast14days.
Andthenakeymoment,DonaldTrumpaskedabout...You'vebeenreferringtoallofthisasahoax
nowsomeonehasdied.Doyoustandbythat?AndTrump,incomprehensivelysaysNo.WhatI
meantwasthat,theholeisonthemontheDemocratswithcover.WhatIjustaskit,yousaidthe
otherdayintheCabinetRoomwithAfrican­Americanleaders,you'vegottogetawayfrompolitics.
YouweredowninCharleston,lastnight.UsingthewordhopeswhentalkingaboutDemocrats
somebodynowisdead,fromthis.Doyouregretthatkindofahookreferringtotheactionthatthey
take,totryandpinthisonsomebody?'causewe'vedonesuchagoodjob,thehopeis,onthem.I'm
nottalkingaboutwhat'shappeninghere,I'mtakingwhatthey'redoing.That'sthehope,that'sjusta
continuationofthehopes,whetherit'stheimpeachmenthopesortheRussia­RussiaHouseiswhat
I'mtalkingabout.
IchallengeanyonetoexplainwhatTrumpmeanshere.Whenhecalleditaho,hemetTheHOSis
onthedemocrats,butit'salsobeingperpetratedbytheDemocrats,theDemocratsarehopingand
beinghosedbutcover19itselfisnotthehoes.Imaginethat.Andthenlastlyhere,backtothetopic
ofAfghanistan.
Trumpinthispartgetsvisiblyconfused.HesaysWenevershouldhavegoneintoAfghanistan
03/03/20 Page5of16
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­02­commercialfree
underObama,ofcourse,wewentinbeforeBarackObama.Trumpseemstorealizeitimmediately
getsconfusedandsays,Actually,weshouldhavegonein.Itbecomesacompleteandtotalmessjust
allup.
Youbroughtyourselfonadealmaker,butyourformerNationalSecurityViceJohnBolen.Issaid
tothisisanObamastyledeal,andsendthewrongmessagetoISISandallkinda...Whatdidthe
Talibangiveuphere?Soyoubehostingthe"TalininWashingtontoCampDavis.Orwillyoumeet
themabroad?Welookatthat.Look,nobodyshouldbecriticisingthisdeal.Ifin19years,hehad
hischancehedidn'tdoit,hewasverymuchinfavorofgoingin.Weshouldhavenevergonein,in
thefirstplace,whenthey...WhatI...That'salistento.
Whentheywentintoarack,whentheywentintotheMiddleEastinsuchafashion,Iwasvery
muchagainstit,shitintoGodgunandhethoughtweshouldhave...That'sbeenprovenwrong.I'm
surprisedthatanybodywouldbeagainstsomethingwherewetryandenda19­yearwarr8100,
milesawayfromourhome.We'vedoneagreatjobinthesensethatwe'vekilledalotofterrorists
we'veput'emoutofcommission.Sothenheactuallysays...Wellno,Idon'tmeanitwasbadfor
ObamatogointoAfghanistan,Imean,Bushshouldn'thavegoneintoarock.Iwasagainstitthat's
alive,from...WentonHoward'sthornandsaidhewasinfavor.Butthisisactuallyallabout
Afghanistananyway,soObama'sopinionorTrump'sopinionaboutbushesarockwar,ithas
nothingtodowithwhatDonaldTrumpisdoinginAfghanistan.Itisnonsensical,rambling.
Igotanemailovertheweekendfromsomeonewhosaid,David,weseethisguyasanignorant
clownbutalotofhisfollowersseethesamepressconferenceandtheyseestrengthandpowerand
aguywho'snotgoingtobemanipulatedbythelivesandthat'sprobablytruethatalotoftrumpsto
seethissamepressconferencethatwayandthat'swhywecan'tconvincethemtovoteforsomeone
otherthanTrumpinNovemberwesimplyhavetogoaroundthem.